[Music]
good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight if you've been watching
this channel we hope you have been you
know the president is rallying his
supporters tonight in southern New
Jersey it's going on right now in fact
this on the screen his supporters
started lining up Sunday afternoon just
to get inside we're monitoring what the
president's talking about news may occur
likely well and we'll have highlights
for you just ahead one thing the
president is almost certain to weigh in
on tonight is the ongoing Senate
impeachment trial which continues to
drag on like a head cold history's most
intensely covered head cold as of
tonight impeachment has received many
times the news coverage of everything
else has happened in the past couple of
weeks combined in America's newsroom
impeachment is all that matters and that
should tell you something
in fact it ought to make you suspicious
the world is changing incredibly fast
out there and it's fascinating and
ominous and worth covering but by and
large the media are all but ignoring it
why are they doing that well consider
the stories they're downplaying in favor
of a protracted government hearing who's
ending we already know for starters at
this very moment a serious viral
outbreak is spreading across China the
world's biggest country in just a matter
of weeks this new strain of coronavirus
has generated almost as many new cases
as SARS did remember SARS is charged it
in three full months so two weeks versus
three months mmm more than a hundred
people have died so far and that's just
the official total the real number
likely higher than that Hong Kong has
closed its borders with mainland China
but as of tonight for reasons that are
not at all clear planes are still
landing in this country from Chinese
cities huh so by any objective standard
that is the biggest story of the day
maybe of the moment a pen potential
pandemic rising from Asia but that's not
all that is happening outside
impeachment world according to a new CDC
report the suicide rate in this country
is risen by an astounding 40 percent
over the past 17 years
last year alone an additional 16,000
Americans killed themselves compared to
the rate from 17 years ago you likely
know one of them most people do know one
of them to put it in perspective that's
more deaths in the entire Iraq and the
entire Afghan war combined
in the hardest-hit sector of the
population you won't be surprised to
learn was blue-collar workers it's the
same group being crushed by wage
stagnation unemployment and the opioid
epidemic and being crushed above all by
the loathing and the contempt a ruling
class so clearly feels for them why are
they dying neglect is one of the main
causes more on that later in the show
meanwhile as if that weren't enough all
of that a well-known Harvard University
professor turns out to be a Chinese spy
for real Charles Lieber chair of
Harvard's chemistry department was
arrested today for concealing millions
of dollars in payments from the Chinese
government and then hiding his
involvement in a Chinese program to
acquire foreign technology and expertise
if those allegations against Lieber are
true he betrayed this country to assist
our most dangerous enemy and he wasn't
alone authorities have also charged what
you were watching impeachment a Boston
University grad student who apparently
was secretly serving as a lieutenant in
the People's Liberation Army forwarded
her research from this country straight
to Beijing that research was already
back in China so she'll likely never be
punished for what she did but yet
another researcher here on a visa
sponsored by yes Harvard was just caught
trying to smuggle 21 vials of biological
material out of Logan Airport in Boston
this is all happening right now
remember when America was shocked when
the Rosenbergs were caught stealing
secrets and sending him to the Soviets
they want the electric chair for that
well today Chinese spies are so common
in our colleges and in our government
here in Washington there would barely
even notice them it doesn't even rate a
story on page one so there you have it
three news stories each more compelling
and more inherently that important than
the impeachment farce we've endured for
a week and a half
what are these stories have in common
well each one points up the selfish and
competence of the people in charge and
maybe that's why the media don't want to
talk about them because their job is to
protect the people in charge by the way
here's one more story they're not
telling you about in any detail the
growing chaos within the Democratic
Party with the first votes the 2020 race
less than a week from now things are
falling apart Bernie Sanders is all of a
sudden poised to win the first three
contests in a row historically that has
been a guarantee of a presidential
nomination now Bernie's rise has been
happening
for months now but like every major new
development in the world it's been slow
to dawn on official Washington which has
been wholly engaged in the emotionally
satisfying ritual of hating Donald Trump
but now Bernie has arrived and he's
impossible to ignore the Democratic
establishment is waking up to a
nightmare and they're horrified no
Democrat in Washington really believes
Joe Biden is a strong candidate no
matter what they tell you talk to them
privately talk to anyone who knows him
and they'll admit Joe Biden shouldn't
even be running or for that matter
driving everyone agrees it said to watch
it their solution their designated
Savior is finance mogul Michael
Bloomberg so an elderly white male
billionaire riding to the rescue of a
party that as a matter of official
policy hates white male billionaires
doesn't sound likely does it if this
were a movie script they'd be laughed
out of the pitch meeting come on no one
will believe it but this is Washington
where purportedly smart people convince
themselves of all kinds of unlikely
things and then go with it
so Bloomberg is the candidate they're
backing for now anyway oh but please
let's stop talking about depressing
topics like Chinese spying global
pandemics and the imminent rise of
socialism in our country let's get back
to something we can handle
something small and fun like John
Bolton's tiny new book good old John
bolt and they hated him once on cable
television now here's the hero why why
did he love John Bolton because his book
and the sideshow it represents makes it
possible for the rest of us to ignore
their failures but it's still
interesting